I know that you've been following events
here very closely and there was that
news conference yesterday where we
learned that the investigation now is
very much focusing on the river they
have been searching now for eight days
we're now into the ninth day
if and it is a big if uh Nicola is in
the river why has it taken so long to
find her
that's what I'm surprised about Jonathan
I mean normally when we scan a river we
can scan about 10 miles a day with our
high frequency sonar is the best in the
world we have available I mean 53 000
pounds worth of equipment but it finds
people quickly and then recovered by
divers this is not a really
um a fast-moving title it's quite slow
it's moving slowly it's quite narrow so
quite straightforward to search I mean
the police divers are doing a great job
but they can only search a small section
at a time but I believe from the news
reports that sonar has been brought in
but sonars is only good as the operator
using it and the frequency I worked okay
on a case on Damien touch in Wales where
he was missing for 18 months it was
searched 12 times with the sonar and
they missed him I found him in 10
minutes when I was called in to find him
in his car so it depends on the operator
it depends on the equipment so we
mustn't get sidetracked with the you
know it's been searched with sonar it
just depends on on on the kit what's
being used
yeah just give us a bit more detail
because it is fascinating technology
this this underwater sonar just just
talked me through how it works
[Applause]
what is Jonathan you tow a missile like
a Miss are you big yellow missile type
object behind the boat on a short cable
it sends sound waves across the seabed
or riverbed and then it hits an object
and brings a return in now because our
ours is 1800 kilohertz it gives me a
crystal clear image of the bottom of the
river every stick every stone laying on
the bottom and if we hit a Target we can
actually measure that Target and a body
if there's a body in a river and
hopefully nickel is not but it it will
show a head arm legs it shows everything
and then we can then pinpoint it it's
the best piece of equipment for
searching water I've heard under
underwater drones are being used but an
underwater drone is effectively remote
operated vehicle on a cable and you
can't you can easily Miss areas and
obviously it's poor visibility and
they're not very effective sonar is the
best way of searching a river
and you've worked with police forces uh
before you have links with your local
police force I understand and and you
have been called on at times to to help
because of your expertise and the
equipment that you have
well we have contracts with Kents Kent
Police exits please sorry Sussex Thames
Valley and Hampshire we are the police
dive team we are the dive team for the
whole of the southeast excluding the
Metro cover London so we are constantly
called We're and that's what we do we
average about 10 drownings every year
where we cover the bodies of drowning
victims suicide victims and search on
for murder victims as well both on land
and in water so we are top of our game
in that particular area
yeah
and if you were part of the team here
what advice would you be giving now what
would be uh uh your priority
well I would be looking firstly you know
is the the evidence we got as a phone
everything's drawn to the river at the
moment obviously we would put our our
sonar in I've worked on cases where
there was a shoe left on the river and
it was left as a decoy we don't know if
this has been left by a third party or
Nicola as a decoy to drag all the
resources down to the River's Edge and
I'd be looking at that very clearly
um how it's got there in the first place
but I would run us our sonar along the
river and I would just see every part of
that River and you could quickly confirm
or deny any anomalies in that River
or perhaps your expertise is something
that could be drawn on in this case
which now as we say is into its ninth
day uh Peter folding uh great to get to
your thoughts thank you uh very much uh
once again good to speak to you